so today we're talking about all of that
juicy elder ring gameplay and how you
can play it early as well as the animal
crossing 2.0 update dropping early my
name is devonte and this is gamespot
news
first off let's talk about that elden
ring gameplay from earlier today because
i am sold
a little bit apprehensive because i'm
not like a from software gamer but
i'm sold regardless in the footage we
are taken to the land between where the
player sees a site of grace this game's
version of a bonfire a suggestion shows
where the player can go next from the
site but it's up to them to determine if
they want to do this or go somewhere
else and unlike other from software
games elden ring will have a map but you
must create it yourself from different
fragments you can use the map icons and
beacons to help you locate things you
found previously taking some influence
from breath of the wild and spirit
springs will let you take your horse
soaring into the air as you traverse new
areas spirits can also be summoned to
assist you in battle and of course there
are pvp invaders to make things more
difficult because of the more open world
structure dungeons can sometimes be
found simply by exploring the world and
they contain their own treasure and
bosses elden ring is set for release in
february 2022 but you may not have to
wait until then to play it as there's a
closed network test beginning november
12th and you can register right now for
a chance to get in
and speaking of playing things early
animal crossing new horizons last major
free update went live sometime last
night almost two days before it was
originally scheduled to drop the early
update was reported across social media
when players received a surprise prompt
to update the game after logging in
while the update wasn't loading
automatically for all players fans
quickly found that it could be force
loaded by pressing the plus button while
animal crossing was selected in the main
menu and then selecting the upgrade
option this is what i had to do i was
very confused at first i was like how is
everyone else getting it why can't i uh
okay now it's working interestingly
nintendo hasn't said anything official
about the early update with the most
recent tweets from the official animal
crossing twitter account simply offering
more details about the upcoming happy
home paradise paid expansion the paid
dlc doesn't appear to be early either
despite having the same plan november
5th release date as the 2.0 update the
25 expansion is still listed for
pre-order in the e-shop but is not yet
accessible
and now it's time for everyone's
favorite segment
is that game you really want delayed
first up ea sports pga tour
delayed the publisher said on wednesday
the game will not be out on schedule in
spring 2022 in a brief statement ea said
it will share more information about the
game's launch plans in the months ahead
however no explanation for the delay was
provided next up marvel's midnight sons
delayed the game is now scheduled for
release in the second half of 2022 in a
statement the studio said it needs more
time to make marvel's midnight suns the
quote best game possible and last up
soulcresta delayed in a stream titled
hideki kamiya's very sorry stream kamiya
revealed the news that the title would
have to be pushed back it now has an
unspecified release date but he hopes to
have a new one sometime in early 2022.
are you looking forward to any of those
let me know in the comments below
so hit the comment section and let me
know if eldon ring is going to be your
first from software game as well
i played like five minutes of bloodborne
i don't know if that counts like
i guess technically like i've i've
downloaded and turned on a from software
game so alden ring wouldn't be my first
whatever
see you next time
[Music]
you